[موسيقى]
حديث سيرا مروع يغير حياه شابه المقدسيه
حنين ابو غوش بلمح البصر ويبعدها على
عجلات متحركه بعد ان كانت فتاه حيويه
تتحرك كثيرا على حسب تعبيرها
اتت تتحول بحياتك كانت
التغيير العمله الكرسي يعني كان تغير 180
درجه كان عند حياتي هيك حيويه
ما عملت انه انا ممكن
اخسر الاشياء اللي اخسر روتين الحقيقه
اللي انا كنت متعوده عليه قررت حنين ان
تعيد جزء من حياتها السابقه فتعلمت
السياقه وبدات تعلم تخصص القانون وتمارس
حنينا اليوم عده العاب رياضيه
ونشاطات متعدده منها الغوص والكيك بوكسنج
والملاكمه
حياتي تحولت 180 درجه بعد نقطه كثير لكثير
الحساسه وهي النقطه الي انا كان في تصالح
بيني وبين الكرسي قبلت الكرسي استوعبت انه
الكرسي هي مش عدو بالعكس هو صاحبه هو
الاذان لانه بستعملها عشان اقدر اتنقل
واروح واجي من المحل الثاني وهو الاذان
لانه بواسطتها راح اقدر اكمل حياتي ماتت
حنين من اهم المتحدثات التحفيزيات من ذوي
الاعاقه في فلسطين وحولت الكرسي الى منبر
كل واحد فينا عنده تحديات بعيش كل يوم
عنده تحديات وبوجهها همم يمكن مرات احنا
ما في ايدينا شيء نعمله يعني ما في شيء
بتعملي
بس اللي بتقدري تعملي انك تغير طريقه
تفكيرك فيه
بعد ان قالت خسرت كل ما املك
تجاوزت حنين العجلات وتقول اليوم امشي الى
القمه دون قدمين تقودني روحي وقلبي
ومثابرتي الى حلمه لا نكون غاصي من القدس
صباح العربيه